Shure: 喜欢告五人
Shure: I like Accusefive
Shure: 咦
Shure: Eh?
Shure: 你那朋友会不会就是啊
Shure: Do you think your friend is...
Shure: 你那朋友是网上认识的吗
Shure: Is your friend someone you met online?
Nicous: 什么朋友
Nicous: What friend?
Shure: 就是你去听那个告五人
Shure: The one you went to listen to Accusefive with
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Shure: 不怪你这真不怪你
Shure: It's not your fault, really not your fault
Shure: 你好杨老板
Shure: Hello, Jake
Jake:要表演了
Jake: It's time to perform
Shure: 那个紫萱
Shure: That Zixuan...
Shure: 不是呸
Shure: No, oops
Shure:  雨雨
Shure: Yuyu
Shure: 雨轩说他想唱歌
Shure: Yuxuan said he wants to sing
Nicous: 你哪个前女友叫紫宣
Nicous: Which ex-girlfriend of yours is called Zixuan?
Shure: 我没有叫紫萱的
Shure: I don't have one named Zixuan
Shure: 我好像都是跟四声有关系
Shure: Seems like all my exes have names with the fourth tone
Nicous: 我知道谁了
Nicous: I know who it is
Nicous: 大佐
Nicous: Da Zuo
Shure: 朱子炫是吗
Shure: Zhu Zixuan, right?
Shure: 哈哈乐死了
Shure: Haha, that's hilarious
Jake:有点沙雕
Jake: A bit silly
Nicous: 我看有个人叫左
Nicous: I saw someone named Zuo
Nicous: 叫柱了
Nicous: Called Zhu
Nicous: 但是不知道为什么我们喊他大佐
Nicous: But for some reason we call him Da Zuo
Nicous: 那我现在喊他左子
Nicous: Now I call him Zuozhu
Shure: 我想想啊
Shure: Let me think
Shure: 我要我要我要我要我要
Shure: I want, I want, I want, I want, I want
Shure: 搜什么啊
Shure: What am I searching for?
Shure: 我要搜soundcrest
Shure: I want to search for soundcrest
Shure: 这时候就可以问AI他为什么要调琴
Shure: At this point you can ask AI why he's tuning the instrument
Shure: 因为我拿起这把琴的时候
Shure: Because when I picked up this instrument
Shure: 发现的这个琴不准
Shure: I found it out of tune
Jake:然后就要进行这个调整
Jake: So you have to make adjustments
Jake:以前没有这个APP的时候怎么调
Jake: How did you tune it before there were apps?
Shure: 你要是问最古老吗
Shure: You mean the oldest method?
Jake:就是之前了
Jake: Just before that
Shure: 对靠那个震动频率
Shure: Yeah, by feeling the vibration frequency
Shure: 然后感受
Shure: And sensing it
Jake: 然后那个多少钱
Jake: And how much did that cost?
Shure: 没没多少钱
Shure: Not much money.
Shure: 怎么回事
Shure: What's going on?
Shure: 几十块钱不到 10新币
Shure: Less than a few dozen bucks, not even 10 SGD.
Shure: 应该 10新币左右
Shure: Should be around 10 SGD.
Jake:300分好
Jake: 300 points, good.
Shure: 好了雨轩老师叫对了
Shure: Alright, Rain called it right.
Shure: 叫对你名了
Shure: Called your name right.
Shure: 要表演了
Shure: Time to perform.
Shure: 你点的轻
Shure: You tapped lightly.
Shure: 点的唯一吗
Shure: Tapped the only one?
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Shure: 在来啊
Shure: Come on, again.
Shure: 彩排我给你唱低八度的和声好吧
Shure: For rehearsal, I'll sing the lower octave harmony, okay?
Shure: 准备好了吗这次
Shure: Ready this time?
Katrina: 看歌词
Katrina: Looking at the lyrics.
Shure: 准备好了
Shure: Ready.
Shure: 这次紫萱老师
Shure: This time, Violet.
Jake:完了
Jake: Done.
Jake:跪下来吧
Jake: Kneel down.
Katrina: 合做终止
Katrina: Cooperation terminated.
Shure: 雨轩老师
Shure: Rain.
Shure: 可以了吗
Shure: Is it okay?
Shure: 这次
Shure: This time.
Jake:来开拍吧
Jake: Come on, start filming.
Jake:我觉得差不多了
Jake: I think it's good enough.
Katrina: 等一下我带上眼镜
Katrina: Wait, let me put on my glasses.
Jake:先连一下
Jake: Let's connect first.
Katrina: 我要看歌词
Katrina: I need to see the lyrics.
Shure: 好那你顺便帮我翻个谱吧好吧
Shure: Okay, can you flip the sheet music for me too?
Katrina: ok
Katrina: Ok.
Shure: 这夹夹好一点
Shure: This clip is better.
Shure: 别出现刚刚那种次音就委尴尬
Shure: Don't let that wrong note happen again, it's embarrassing.
Katrina: 我们宿舍有人会弹吉它
Katrina: Someone in our dorm can play guitar.
Katrina: 然后就
Katrina: And then...
Shure: 来吧 ready
Shure: Come on, ready.
Katrina: 还没连接上
Katrina: Not connected yet.
Shure: 这个夹子有点不紧
Shure: This clip isn't tight enough.
Shure: 嗯 你看
Shure: Hmm, look.
Shure: 给它反过来 夹一下
Shure: Turn it over and clip it.
Katrina: 音不准吗
Katrina: Is the pitch off?
Shure: 不是这个夹子有点夹不紧有点松
Shure: No, this clip isn't tight enough, it's a bit loose.
Shure: 对啊
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina: 录一下
Katrina: Record it.
Shure: ok来吧
Shure: Okay, let's go.
Katrina: 录到你的洞洞鞋
Katrina: Record your Crocs.
Shure: 哈哈你搞搞事情了是吗
Shure: Haha, are you up to something?
Katrina: 哈哈有点赖吧
Katrina: Haha, a bit lazy, right?
Jake:常务记一下这个
Jake: Note this down.
Jake:5:1017:11
Jake: 5:1017:11
Katrina: 直接给你这样吧
Katrina: Let me just give it to you like this.
Jake:对对叫什么呀
Jake: Yeah, yeah, what's it called?
Shure: 对齐
Shure: Align it.
Katrina: 但我穿睡
Katrina: But I wear...
Katrina: 来吧
Katrina: Come on.
Shure: 停停停卡卡卡卡
Shure: Stop, stop, stop, cut, cut, cut.
Jake:我的虫虫
Jake: My bug.
Jake:对了鬼关了好好
Jake: Right, ghost off, okay.
Katrina: 重来
Katrina: Start over.
Katrina: 卡了最后一句
Katrina: Stuck on the last sentence.
Katrina: 没了
Katrina: Done.
Shure: 非常好
Shure: Very good.
Shure: 雨轩老师唱功了得
Shure: Teacher Yuxuan's singing skills are amazing.
Shure: 雨轩老师还有什么想唱的歌
Shure: Teacher Yuxuan, any other songs you want to sing?
Shure: 我尽量的都帮你弹一弹
Shure: I'll try to play them all for you.
Katrina: 呃
Katrina: Uh...
Katrina: 我看看
Katrina: Let me see.
Katrina: 我还有什么想唱的
Katrina: What else do I want to sing?
Katrina: 你都能弹
Katrina: You can play them all?
Katrina: 噢 泪桥你听过没有
Katrina: Oh, have you heard of "Tear Bridge"?
Katrina: 伍佰的那个
Katrina: The one by Wu Bai.
Shure: 那我应该知道
Shure: Then I should know it.
Katrina: 唉这也一了半天
Katrina: Ah, this too, for half a day.
Shure: 是这个调调吧
Shure: Is it this tune?
Katrina: 好像有点高
Katrina: Seems a bit high.
Shure: 不不不会唱这个是
Shure: No, no, I can't sing this.
Katrina: 这好像是伍佰原版就是偏摇滚的那种
Katrina: This seems like Wu Bai's original rock version.
Katrina: 就被人改编偏民谣的那种感觉
Katrina: It was adapted to a folk style.
Katrina: 我看看啊还有什么比较熟悉的
Katrina: Let me see if there are any other familiar ones.
Katrina: 小雨你听过吗甘小雨
Katrina: Xiaoyu, have you heard "Gan Xiaoyu"?
Shure: 是张仁岳的那个吗
Shure: Is it the one by Zhang Renyue?
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yes
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay
Katrina: 这些歌我觉得很适合你吉它弹
Katrina: I think these songs are perfect for you to play on the guitar.
Shure: 降半音式C调效式D调阀音
Shure: Half-step down tuning in C, effective tuning in D, valve sound
Shure: 要唱他的原原调的是吗
Shure: Do you want to sing it in the original key?
Katrina: 我不知道啊
Katrina: I don't know.
Katrina: 你会唱吗你要带一下
Katrina: Can you sing it? Can you lead?
Shure: 好 我试一下
Shure: Sure, I'll give it a try.
Katrina: 你弹到哪了
Katrina: Where are you at with the playing?
Katrina: 弹完啦
Katrina: Finished playing?
Katrina: 哎
Katrina: Hey
Shure: 配合默契挺好啊
Shure: We have great coordination.
Katrina: 咱五两那个
Katrina: Our five taels?
Katrina: 最后一句不会
Katrina: I can't do the last line.
Katrina: 好后面这首高潮
Katrina: Okay, the climax of the next song
Katrina: 你带
Katrina: You lead
Shure: 可以
Shure: Okay
Katrina: 可以 来唱歌吧
Katrina: Okay, let's sing.
Katrina: 来唱歌
Katrina: Let's sing.
Shure: 毫无默契
Shure: No coordination at all.
Katrina: 完全拉跨
Katrina: Completely off.
Katrina: 你噫 什么你们这些有女朋友的
Katrina: Ugh, what's up with you guys who have girlfriends?
Katrina: 好第一天坐你们车的时候知道学姐跟我说
Katrina: On the first day I rode in your car, the senior told me.
Katrina: 她女朋友绝望吧
Katrina: His girlfriend must be desperate.
Katrina: 我说哦靠都有女朋友一车
Katrina: I was like, wow, everyone in the car has a girlfriend.
Katrina: 她是晒衣服吗
Katrina: Is she hanging clothes?
Katrina: 我们坐在伞下你坐进来
Katrina: We're sitting under the umbrella, come sit with us.
Shure: freestyle一段
Shure: Freestyle a bit.
Katrina: 嗯从哪开始呢
Katrina: Hmm, where should we start?
Katrina: 还是前观比较熟
Katrina: Still familiar with the front part.
Shure: 我意思是你根据我的这个
Shure: I mean, you go along with my...
Katrina: 啊我听不出啥调
Katrina: Ah, I can't tell the key.
Shure: 想到什么唱什么
Shure: Just sing whatever comes to mind.
Shure: 试一下嗯
Shure: Give it a try, yeah.
Katrina: 唉不行
Katrina: Oh no.
Katrina: 这下这下难受了
Katrina: This is tough.
Katrina: 让他唱
Katrina: Let him sing.
Shure: 傻子
Shure: Idiot.
Katrina: 你们俩一个宿舍的吗
Katrina: Are you two roommates?
Katrina: 是他在我隔壁不打
Katrina: He's next door, doesn't hit.
Katrina: 不是 他在我隔壁
Katrina: No, he's next to me.
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Katrina: 这是你自已随便调的啊
Katrina: Did you just randomly tune this yourself?
Katrina: 哎还挺好听耶
Katrina: Oh, it sounds pretty good.
Shure: 下雨了
Shure: It's raining.
Nicous: 吉它给我试下唯一
Nicous: Let me try the guitar for "The Only."
Katrina: 这这都那个弹得老天都哭了
Katrina: This playing is so good it's making the heavens cry.
Katrina: 来吧今天就主攻唯一了
Katrina: Come on, let's focus on "The Only" today.
Nicous: 教我一下
Nicous: Teach me.
Shure: 好
Shure: Sure.
Katrina: 你也为弹吉它啊
Katrina: You can play the guitar too?
Shure: 他可以速速成一下
Shure: He can pick it up quickly.
Katrina: 唯一有那个吗
Katrina: Does "The Only" have that?
Nicous: 把我的琴带了
Nicous: I brought my guitar.
Shure: 什么琴
Shure: What guitar?
Shure: 钢琴
Shure: Piano.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 这不是唯一
Shure: This isn't "The Only."
Katrina: 唯一被你删了是不是
Katrina: Did you delete "The Only"?
Shure: 就是
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 你不用管他这个
Shure: Don't worry about that.
Shure: 这个你摁到摁到这个1 2
Shure: Just press this, this 1, 2.
Katrina: 刚学啊这是
Katrina: Is this just learning?
Shure: 3 对这样
Shure: 3, yeah, like this.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Shure: 不对
Shure: No, not right.
Shure: 没摁上食指食指往上窜一点对嗯
Shure: Your index finger needs to move up a bit, yeah.
Shure: 你可以不用摁着弹
Shure: You don't need to press while playing.
Shure: 你别看这不用弹前奏了
Shure: Don't look at it, don't play the intro.
Shure: 你就把和弦先摁明白得了
Shure: Just understand the chords first.
Shure: 还想弹前奏
Shure: Still thinking about playing the intro.
Shure: 悟性很高
Shure: Your understanding is high.
Katrina: 录一个你发你女朋友吧
Katrina: Record one and send it to your girlfriend.
Shure: 这个可以
Shure: That can work.
Katrina: 刚录上
Katrina: Just recorded it.
Shure: EM就可以只摁这两
Shure: EM, just press these two.
Shure: 不不不用弹那个
Shure: No, no, don't play that.
Shure: 只摁这俩
Shure: Just press these two.
Shure: 对吧
Shure: Right?
Katrina: 去
Katrina: Go.
Shure: 看谁不轻易
Shure: Watch who doesn't take it lightly.
Shure: 嗯魔音罐耳
Shure: Hmm, magic sound canister.
Shure: 我已经成功教会谢彬竹吉它了
Shure: I've successfully taught Xie Binzhu the guitar.
Jake:弹一弹一首
Jake: Play a song.
Jake:这个应该怎么弹全吗
Jake: How should we play this entirely?
Shure: 就这个样
Shure: Just like this.
Shure: 你可以同时
Shure: You can simultaneously...
Nicous: OK我已经悟了
Nicous: OK, I've got it.
Shure: 你悟个蛋
Shure: Got it, my foot.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha.
Shure: 或者你这样爬音会更更好听一点
Shure: Or you could do this, it might sound a bit better.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Katrina: 他为啥金鸡独立呀
Katrina: Why is he standing on one leg?
Shure: 因为他坐着呢
Shure: Because he's sitting.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Shure: 他没有眼力见有些人
Shure: Some people just don't have the sense.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 好你夺权吧
Shure: Alright, you take over then.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Katrina: 音绕梁
Katrina: The sound lingers.
Shure: 没事没事无所谓
Shure: It's okay, it's okay, no big deal.
Jake:他怎么样挺好
Jake: How is he? Pretty good?
Shure: 有天赋
Shure: He's talented.
Shure: 说实话挺好
Shure: Honestly, he's pretty good.
Shure: 就是有的音没出音哦
Shure: Just some notes didn't come out.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈你真的爱他吗哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha, do you really love him? Hahahaha.
Katrina: 犹豫了
Katrina: Hesitated.
Jake:我草
Jake: Oh shit.
Shure: 喂你好
Shure: Hello?
Katrina: 哎呀搞蒙了
Katrina: Oh no, I'm confused.
Shure: 啊您京东快递到了是吗
Shure: Ah, your JD.com delivery is here?
Shure: 啊行我马上马上取一下
Shure: Ah, okay, I'll pick it up right away.
Katrina: 你应该是学过一点吧
Katrina: You must have studied a bit, right?
Shure: 啊知道吧
Shure: Ah, you know, right?
Shure: 啊您您要不给我先放放这先
Shure: Ah, can you leave it there for me first?
Katrina: 有的他要琢磨半天按哪几格
Katrina: Sometimes he has to think for a while about which frets to press.
Shure: 啊啊啊
Shure: Ah, ah, ah.
Shure: 那反正我们这边好像让什么管家去取
Shure: Anyway, it seems like we have someone to pick it up.
Shure: 应该你就放放在那应该他就能找到
Shure: You can just leave it there, they should be able to find it.
Shure: 啊好嘞成谢谢你
Shure: Ah, okay, thanks a lot.
Katrina: 哎呀没点东西
Katrina: Oh no, I didn't get anything.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Shure: em正常要怎么按
Shure: Um, how do you normally press it?
Shure: 他那个是EM钢狙是以狙狙为根音的
Shure: His EM steel sniper is based on the root note of the sniper.
Shure: EM正常是这么按
Shure: EM is normally pressed like this.
Shure: 正常不是
Shure: Normally not.
Shure: 正常就是他就是这么按的
Shure: Normally, this is how it's pressed.
Shure: 这是正常的EM因为它的根音是咪这样
Shure: This is the normal EM because its root note is "mi".
Shure: 然后它那是EM杠狙嘛
Shure: And that one is EM steel sniper.
Shure: 就是它的根根音是这样的
Shure: Its root note is like this.
Shure: 你也可以
Shure: You can also...
Shure: 我也没不知道有什么其他办法可以
Shure: I don't know if there's any other way to do it.
Shure: 应该可以这样
Shure: It should be like this.
Shure: 人类早期驯服吉他影像实录
Shure: Early human attempts at taming the guitar, live footage.
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thank you.
Shure: 你好哎呦
Shure: Hi, oh!
快递员：这个在有只能明天取了
Courier: You can only pick this up tomorrow.
Shure: 好的好的
Shure: Okay, okay.
Shure: 会唱私奔吗
Shure: Can you sing "Eloping"?
Katrina: 你京东这是买啥 呀
Katrina: What did you buy from JD?
Shure: 咖啡绿植
Shure: Coffee and plants.
Shure: 就这么无趣
Shure: So boring.
Shure: 这够简单了哥
Shure: This is simple enough, bro.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Nicous: 妈妈说
Nicous: Mom says...
Shure: 妈妈说是谁的
Shure: Who's Mom says?
Shure: 不用想这更更难想象
Shure: Don't think, it's even harder to imagine.
Shure: 就告5人
Shure: Just tell five people.
Shure: 我跟你讲
Shure: I'm telling you.
Shure: 就这仨和弦从头到尾就哭哭弹
Shure: With these three chords, just strum all the way.
Nicous: 这个就不弹直接过好吧
Nicous: Let's skip this part, okay?
Shure: 你可以这样
Shure: You can do this.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina: 你也纱球纱球
Katrina: You too, shasha!
Shure: 对然后在哪歘歘歘
Shure: Yeah, and then like this.
Shure: 别搜了这样弹不来的
Shure: Don't search, you can't play it like this.
Shure: 你别这么说
Shure: Don't say that.
Shure: 我给你搜来
Shure: I'll find it for you.
Shure: 百度AI助力中国航天是什么
Shure: What is Baidu AI's role in supporting China's space program?
Shure:  妈妈说
Shure: Mom said...
Katrina:  我也不知道回啥了
Katrina: I don't even know how to respond.
Katrina:  还要回吗
Katrina: Do I still need to reply?
Shure: 什吗
Shure: What?
Katrina:  就是她说的那个话以后
Katrina: Just what she said after that.
Shure:  没事
Shure: It's fine.
Katrina:  大师你怎么说
Katrina: Master, what do you think?
Shure: 我看看他说什么来着
Shure: Let me see what he said.
Nicous:  好吧男的女的
Nicous: Okay, was it a guy or a girl?
Nicous:  老了少了
Nicous: Older or younger?
Katrina:  我回啥
Katrina: What should I reply?
Katrina:  他跟我说他不想谈爱
Katrina: He told me he doesn't want to talk about love.
Shure:  哦对对对
Shure: Oh, right, right.
Shure:  废话你他妈的呵呵呵呵
Shure: Of course, you idiot, haha.
Katrina:  瞎讲讲半天他妈服务器没开一个地方
Katrina: Talking nonsense all this time and the server wasn't even on.
Shure: 脑袋
Shure: Brain...
Shure:  哎呀哎呀嗯嗯
Shure: Oh my, oh my.
Nicous:  北欧那个
Nicous: That Nordic guy.
Katrina:  嗯嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Nicous:  跟你谈恋爱了
Nicous: Is he in love with you?
Shure:  哎呦我的妈呀
Shure: Oh my goodness.
Nicous:  打开我看地一下
Nicous: Let me take a look.
Katrina:  没谈上人家又说不想谈恋
Katrina: He didn't even start and now he's saying he doesn't want to.
Nicous:  哦他说不想谈这这个不想谈就不谈
Nicous: Oh, he said he doesn't want to talk about it, so don't.
Shure:  爱
Shure: Love.
Shure:  他现在只有单线程
Shure: Right now, he's single-threaded.
Shure:  我跟你讲他很暴躁
Shure: I'm telling you, he's very irritable.
Katrina:  那就不回了
Katrina: Then just don't reply.
Katrina:  不知道回啥
Katrina: I don't know what to say.
Katrina:  这人真怪呀
Katrina: This person is so weird.
Katrina:  你觉得呢还是说你也这样
Katrina: What do you think? Or are you the same way?
Shure:  我不这样啊我要真喜欢我就哭哭晚上冲
Shure: I'm not like that. If I really liked someone, I'd cry and then rush to them at night.
Shure:  我觉你看我在一颗树上吊死四年了
Shure: Look, I've been stuck on one person for four years.
Shure:  哦我还没说完呢
Shure: Oh, I haven't finished yet.
Shure:  之前那个跟另一个女关系特好的时候然后她那个
Shure: When I was really close with another girl before, she...
Shure:  有段时间在实习嘛
Shure: There was a time when she was interning.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Shure:  嗯然后实习结束了
Shure: And then her internship ended.
Shure:  说找我那个出去喝个酒
Shure: She said we should go out for a drink.
Shure:  放松一下
Shure: Relax a bit.
Jake: 要不就
Jake: Or maybe...
Shure: 然后我就去了
Shure: Then I went.
Shure: 嗯然后那天
Shure: Yeah, so that day...
Shure: 然后就跟我正在关系好的那个女生说
Shure: I talked to the girl I was close with.
Shure: 我今天天气很不错耶然后
Shure: I said, "The weather's nice today," and then...
Shure: 我直接把这句话给打断了
Shure: I interrupted myself.
Shure:  但是我今天要跟前女友出去喝酒
Shure: But today I'm going out drinking with my ex.
Katrina:  你也够抽象啊
Katrina: You're so abstract.
Katrina:  他不是正跟你聊得好吗
Katrina: Wasn't he chatting with you nicely?
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure:  但是就是你知道
Shure: But, you know...
Shure:  在我这个脑子系统下
Shure: In my brain's system...
Shure:  下一页要他们付费的
Shure: The next page requires them to pay.
Shure: 付费个头可以
Shure: Pay up, okay?
Nicous:  可麻烦了耶
Nicous: That's such a hassle.
Shure:  就在我的脑子里面
Shure: In my mind...
Shure: 他永远排在一个最优先
Shure: She always has the highest priority.
Katrina:  啊就是前女友永远适合这样
Katrina: Ah, so your ex always fits that role.
Shure:  对
Shure: Yes.
Katrina: 然后呢
Katrina: And then?
Shure:  不知道我不知道他他当时谈
Shure: I don't know, I don't know if she was dating someone.
Shure:  反正我我不在乎他谈没谈
Shure: Anyway, I didn't care if she was dating or not.
Shure:  就是当时
Shure: Just at that time...
Shure:  一直就是把他当出来喝酒一起玩的朋友那种
Shure: I always saw her as a friend to go out drinking with.
Katrina: 啊这样子
Katrina: Ah, I see.
Shure:  就是咋唱都不记你还在这弹呢
Shure: No matter how you sing, you're still playing it.
Shure:  你先你先学咋唱
Shure: Learn how to sing first.
Nicous: 你先帮我把第二页绑起来
Nicous: Help me bind the second page first.
Shure:  你先把第一页学会我给你搞
Shure: Learn the first page first, then I'll help you.
Katrina:  哎我好像听过这个歌
Katrina: Hey, I think I've heard this song before.
Katrina:  像你家晕的比较轻偏RNB
Katrina: Sounds like your style, a bit R&B.
Shure:  的时代已经过去了
Shure: 调一下
Shure: Tune it a bit.
Shure:  你再从从头放一下
Shure: Play it from the beginning again.
Shure:  你不要从这么头
Shure: Not from that beginning.
Shure: 打个灯
Shure: Turn on a light.
Shure: 我草
Shure: Damn.
Shure:  大点声音乐
Shure: Turn up the music volume.
Jake: 雨轩老师
Jake: Teacher Yuxuan.
Jake: 你的快递那个笔有到吗
Jake: Did your package with the pen arrive?
Katrina:  不知道他取没有
Katrina: I don't know if he picked it up.
Jake: 看对看一下
Jake: Check it out.
Jake: 如果有的话能有点用
Jake: If it's there, it might be useful.
Katrina:  他说已签收啊
Katrina: He said it's been signed for.
Katrina:  那他去拿了吧
Katrina: So he must have picked it up.
Katrina:  已签收没签收的话他会发
Katrina: If it's signed for, he would have sent it.
Jake: 嗯嗯嗯看一看
Jake: Hmm, let's take a look.
Shure:  这个四五
Shure: This is 4-5.
Shure:  我们可以一起创作一些非常简单的东西
Shure: We can create some really simple stuff together.
Katrina:  可以
Katrina: Sure.
Shure:  就比如说随便弹一个掉的 1645
Shure: Like just randomly play a 1-6-4-5 chord progression.
Shure:  就这种
Shure: Like this.
Shure:  好雨宣老师填词
Shure: Okay, Yu Xuan, fill in the lyrics.
Shure:  啥玩意现在就拿着你的论文开始唱出来
Shure: Whatever, just start singing with your thesis.
Katrina:  草履虫变异
Katrina: Paramecium mutation.
Shure:  我觉得草
Shure: I think...
Katrina:  别说我以前还干过挺蠢的事追星的时候干过
Katrina: Don't say it, I used to do some silly things when I was a fangirl.
Katrina:  帮人家站填词
Katrina: I helped write lyrics for fans.
Katrina:  然后我就决定换一个小夜灯
Katrina: Then I decided to change to a small night light.
Katrina: 但是那是有原来的词
Katrina: But those were the original lyrics.
Katrina:  然后你在去押韵
Katrina: Then you rhyme it.
Shure:  我们就叫草履虫变异来吧
Shure: Let's call it Paramecium Mutation.
Katrina: 草履虫变异了
Katrina: Paramecium mutated.
Shure:  然后还有什么
Shure: And what else?
Shure:  哈哈哒哒哒
Shure: Haha, da da da.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure:  叫什么命题作文
Shure: What's it called, a prompt-based essay?
Katrina:  草履虫草履虫
Katrina: Paramecium, Paramecium.
Katrina:  变异
Katrina: Mutation.
Shure:  好你又学会了
Shure: Okay, you've learned it.
Nicous:  他估计就是爱
Nicous: He probably just loves...
Shure:  对韩黛姬对
Shure: Yeah, Han Daeki.
Shure:  爱很简单
Shure: Love is simple.
Katrina:  我靠唱这首歌
Katrina: Wow, singing this song.
Katrina:  给你看这个
Katrina: Look at this.
Shure:  这是谁写的
Shure: Who wrote this?
Katrina: 北邮男
Katrina: A boy from Beiyou.
Shure:  哈哈哈哎
Shure: Hahaha, hey.
Katrina:  当时我俩不是一起去看那个音乐节吗
Katrina: Didn't we go to that music festival together?
Katrina:  然后去听陶喆
Katrina: And then go listen to David Tao.
Katrina:  然后这是那一首嗯
Katrina: And then there's this one song, um...
Katrina:  叫什么
Katrina: What's it called?
Katrina:  是爱很简单吗
Katrina: Is it "Love is Simple"?
Katrina:  不是爱很简单
Katrina: No, not "Love is Simple".
Katrina:  就是爱你就是爱你那首的词
Katrina: It's "Just Love You", the lyrics of that song.
Katrina:  我说我特喜欢这词
Katrina: I said I really love those lyrics.
Katrina:  我说就是对我来说就很有意义吧
Katrina: I said they are very meaningful to me.
Katrina:  然后他第二天早上把我送到高铁站的时候
Katrina: Then the next morning when he took me to the high-speed rail station,
Katrina:  一句话没说
Katrina: He didn't say a word.
Katrina:  然后给我塞一张纸条说高铁上看
Katrina: And then he slipped me a note saying "read it on the train".
Shure:  哎呀他好坏呀他
Shure: Oh, he's so bad, isn't he?
Shure:  他这个歌
Shure: That song of his...
Shure:  我靠都给你吊成翘嘴了我跟你讲
Shure: Damn, he's got you hooked, I'm telling you.
Katrina:  所以所以这么久了还没有完全忘掉吗
Katrina: So, so after all this time, I still haven't completely forgotten, huh?
Katrina:  然后那天去看脱口秀特搞笑你知道吗
Katrina: Then that day, we went to see a comedy show, it was so funny, you know?
Katrina:  我给他看他看我手机那里面的东西
Katrina: I showed him, he looked at the stuff on my phone.
Katrina:  看他他说哎你说换手机他就换
Katrina: He saw it and said, "Hey, you should change your phone, so he did".
Katrina:  马上哈哈哈哈当时看看我咬的哈哈
Katrina: Immediately, hahaha, at that time, I was like, haha.
Shure:  哈他在钓你你快咬钩吧
Shure: Haha, he's baiting you, you should bite the hook.
Shure:  你应该跟他说等等我
Shure: You should tell him to wait for you.
Shure:  我这就上钩
Shure: I'm taking the bait right now.
Katrina:  被吊这么久了呀
Katrina: I've been hooked for so long.
Katrina:  11月份到现在
Katrina: Since November till now.
Katrina:  觉得不能
Katrina: I feel like I can't.
Shure: 一会谢冰珠手打结了
Shure: Soon, Xie Bingzhu will get a knot in her hand.
Katrina:  陶喆歌可难了
Katrina: David Tao's songs are really hard.
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Shure:  哎呦我操你好像高潮了一样哈哈哈
Shure: Oh my god, you look like you just climaxed, hahaha.
Shure:  哎呀我操
Shure: Oh my god.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahaha.
Katrina:  每次那个演唱会和那个音乐节最后
Katrina: Every time at the end of a concert or music festival,
Katrina:  都是这首歌
Katrina: It's always this song.
Katrina:  每次听都哭
Katrina: Every time I hear it, I cry.
Tasha: 边呢
Tasha: Where's the edge?
Shure:  真的简单吗这个感
Shure: Is this feeling really simple?
Shure:  你也可以不按他这个你就只弹和弦
Shure: You can also just play the chords without following him exactly.
Shure:  对这样你就不用先考虑
Shure: Yeah, that way you don't have to think too much.
Shure:  你先把就是
Shure: Just start with...
Shure:  哎这还居然是三色光
Shure: Wow, this is actually three-color light.
Lucia: 这样比较好看
Lucia: It looks better this way.
Lucia: 对就它
Lucia: Yes, just like that.
Lucia: 然后打打开就是这样的
Lucia: And when you open it, it looks like this.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈哈他好装啊这个人
Shure: Hahaha, this guy is so pretentious.
Shure:  死装男真的就是你的墙来了是吧
Shure: The ultimate poser, your idol has arrived, right?
Shure:  深情
Shure: So passionate.
Nicous: 哇靠 手要断了
Nicous: Wow, my hand is about to break.
Nicous: 我给你看我跟我女朋友第一见面分开之后
Nicous: Let me show you what happened after I first met my girlfriend.
Nicous: 你会不会写个纸条吗
Nicous: Can you write a note?
Katrina: 哦你那信是不是我看你朋友圈的
Katrina: Oh, is that the letter I saw on your social media?
Nicous: 那我信我没发过
Nicous: No, I never posted that letter.
Nicous: 不是很 在这里
Nicous: Not really, it's right here.
Nicous: 这么多 哦靠
Nicous: So many, oh my gosh.
Nicous:  不我科普电影啊
Nicous: No, I'm explaining the movie to you.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Nicous:  门忘关了
Nicous: The door was left open.
Katrina: 可以看吗
Katrina: Can I see it?
Nicous: 可以看没有什么东西
Nicous: You can see it, there's nothing important.
Shure:  他都把手机给你了
Shure: He even gave you his phone.
Shure:  你问这么冒昧的话
Shure: And you ask such direct questions.
Katrina: 好有文化呀
Katrina: So cultured.
Katrina:  还有古诗词
Katrina: Even ancient poetry.
Shure:  古人云
Shure: As the ancients said...
Katrina: 当时是你主动这样的
Katrina: Was it you who took the initiative back then?
Katrina: 她主动的
Katrina: She took the initiative.
Shure:  我妈竟然还给我打电话说她好紧张
Shure: My mom actually called me saying she was so nervous.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure:  五一回家
Shure: Going home for May Day.
Shure:  好像回来还得答辩的啊
Shure: Seems like I still have to do a defense when I get back.
Shure:  我妈竟然问我
Shure: My mom actually asked me.
Shure:  你说你这谈的到底认不认真
Shure: She asked if I was serious about this relationship.
Lucia: 家里人给我打电话啦
Lucia: My family called me.
Shure:  你说妈用不用给包红包啥的呀
Shure: She asked if she should give a red envelope or something.
Shure:  哎呀天
Shure: Oh my gosh.
Katrina: 有意思
Katrina: Interesting.
Shure:  哎呀这给我妈整的紧张
Shure: Oh my, my mom is so nervous.
Shure:  他说住住家方便吗
Shure: She asked if staying at home was convenient.
Nicous: 住家 我草
Nicous: Staying at home? Oh my gosh.
Shure:  住酒店是不是有点有点生分呐
Shure: Staying at a hotel might be a bit too formal, right?
Shure:  没有那种家的感觉
Shure: It doesn't feel like home.
Shure:  到底咋整啊
Shure: What should we do?
Shure:  儿子
Shure: Son
Shure:  呵呵我说你问我
Shure: Haha, you asked me.
Nicous: 是不是
Nicous: Right?
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina: 刚在一起 我觉得特
Katrina: When we first got together, I felt very...
Katrina:
Katrina:  我感觉你看我觉得我那个什么暧昧
Katrina: I felt, you know, it was kind of ambiguous.
Katrina:  我要三个月
Katrina: I needed three months.
Katrina:  我才能确定自己不是那种三分钟热度
Katrina: To make sure I wasn't just in it for the thrill.
Katrina:  然后呢
Katrina: And then
Katrina:  在一起之后就感觉只是喜欢算不上爱
Katrina: After we got together, it felt like just liking, not love.
Katrina:  你知道吧
Katrina: You know?
Katrina:  然后又感觉没法跟人说什么我爱你
Katrina: And then I felt like I couldn't say "I love you."
Shure:  确实
Shure: Indeed.
Katrina: 他这可能是我
Katrina: Maybe it's because I...
Katrina: 我我我
Katrina: I, I, I...
Nicous: 就是负责人的
Nicous: Just being responsible.
Shure:  你快偷点哦
Shure: Hurry up and cheat a little.
Shure:  你知道我语文特差
Shure: You know my Chinese is terrible.
Shure:  我语文高考
Shure: My Chinese exam...
Shure:  你们那语文高考满分多少
Shure: What's the full score of your Chinese exam?
Katrina: 我们江苏卷
Katrina: Our Jiangsu paper.
Katrina: 呃 咱俩应该考的一样的啊
Katrina: Uh, we should have taken the same, right?
Nicous: 我满分
Nicous: I got full marks.
Katrina: 你真开玩笑还是
Katrina: Are you joking or...
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yeah.
Shure:  靠近南京
Shure: Near Nanjing.
Shure:  我是写不来一点
Shure: I can't write anything.
Shure:  真写不出来
Shure: Really can't write anything.
Shure:  我是一只草履虫是吧
Shure: I'm like a paramecium, right?
Shure:  还装起来了穿个睡衣尺坐在院子里面
Shure: Even dressed up, wearing pajamas, sitting in the yard.
Shure:  真以为自己是明星啊是吧
Shure: Really think you're a star, right?
Katrina: 是吧
Katrina: Right?
Shure:  他可能跟我一样
Shure: He might be like me.
Shure:  有着一个永远排在top one的一个
Shure: Always having a top one.
Shure: 因为你腿无力
Shure: Because your legs are weak.
Shure: 你虚的
Shure: You're weak.
Shure:  谢彬竹啊
Shure: Xie Binzhu, huh?
Shure:  来自远方的情在向你问好
Shure: Greetings from afar
Shure:  这就可以给他录了
Shure: You can record it now
Shure:  你的爱真简单呐
Shure: Your love is really simple
Shure:  哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha
Shure:  他们根本没搞你
Shure: They didn't mess with you at all
Shure:  放心谁谁会拿你占那么多内存真的
Shure: Don't worry, no one will take up that much of your memory, really
Shure:  随便录一下就好
Shure: Just record it casually
Jake: 晚上吃什么呢ok开始吧
Jake: What should we eat tonight? Okay, let's start
Katrina:  大一点还是头小
Katrina: Bigger or smaller head?
Shure:  看出你的爱虽然简单但很深沉
Shure: I can see that your love, though simple, is very deep
Shure:  切一切就能stop
Shure: Just cut it and it will stop
Jake: 吃什么呢晚上
Jake: What to eat tonight?
Shure: 晚上
Shure: Tonight
Shure:  你两这边是交换名片
Shure: You two are exchanging business cards here
Shure:  哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha
Nicous: 你说我有天赋吗
Nicous: Do you think I have talent?
Shure:  你太有了
Shure: You definitely do
Shure:  你马上就可以成为Guitar master
Shure: You can become a guitar master soon
Shure:  你有了
Shure: You got it
Shure:  你那个三分主要胜在了神韵上
Shure: Your three-pointer mainly won because of its charm
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Haha
Shure:  不不这是交换名片
Shure: No no, this is exchanging business cards
Shure:  你先把照片打开
Shure: First, open the photo
Shure:  然后点这个
Shure: Then click this
Shure:  然后点照
Shure: Then click photo
Shure:  然后play
Shure: Then play
Shure:  然后那个分享
Shure: Then share it
Shure:  然后然后怼他
Shure: Then, then aim at him
Shure:  怼他脸对怼他
Shure: Aim at his face, aim at him
Shure:  嘣
Shure: Boom
Jake:吃什么呀
Jake: What to eat?
Jake: 有什么我们还没吃到的
Jake: Is there anything we haven't tried yet?
Jake: 中国特色食物呢
Jake: Any Chinese specialty food?
Katrina: 我们推荐一下呗
Shure:  卤煮吃过吗
Shure: Have you tried Lu Zhu?
Shure:  但是一般人接受不了
Shure: But most people can't accept it
Jake: 确实有可能
Jake: That's probably true
Shure:  就是我特爱吃卤煮
Shure: I just love Lu Zhu
Nicous: 你吃过豆汁吗
Nicous: Have you tried Douzhi?
Shure:  我没吃过
Shure: I haven't tried it
Jake: 你要不咱就点豆汁吧
Jake: How about we order some fermented mung bean juice?
Shure: 你滚哈哈哈哈可以啊
Shure: Get lost, hahaha, okay sure.
Katrina: 那天不是拿了一瓶吗
Katrina: Didn't we have a bottle the other day?
Jake:可以
Jake: Yes.
Katrina: 拿了一瓶
Katrina: We had a bottle.
Jake:拿了一瓶
Jake: We had a bottle.
Nicous: 那我可以尝呗
Nicous: Can I try it?
Nicous: 听说是中年老头的腋下
Nicous: I heard it smells like an old man's armpit.
Jake: 试试
Jake: Give it a try.
Jake: 那主食呢
Jake: What about the main dish?
Shure:  不不不不不
Shure: No no no no no.
Shure:  来来来正经想一下吃什么
Shure: Come on, let's seriously think about what to eat.
Jake: 你有点OK
Jake: Do you have some ideas?
Shure:  嗯 我有点
Shure: Yeah, I have some.
Jake: 然后噢好吃啥
Jake: Alright, so what to eat?
Shure:  吃啥想想吃啥不行就
Shure: Think about what to eat, if nothing works then...
Jake: 面
Jake: Noodles.
Jake: 吃过面吗
Jake: Have you had noodles?
Shure: 哦面没吃过
Shure: Oh, I haven't had noodles.
Jake: 嗯吃啥面了
Jake: Hmm, what kind of noodles?
Shure:  李先生牛肉面
Shure: Mr. Lee's beef noodles.
Jake:炸酱面
Jake: Zhajiangmian.
Nicous:  哈哈哈李先生牛肉面还有北京牛肉面
Nicous: Hahaha, Mr. Lee's beef noodles, there's also Beijing beef noodles.
Jake: 哦真的没有
Jake: Oh really, there's none.
Shure:  没有这没有北京特色
Shure: There's no Beijing specialty.
Shure:  但是他很好吃
Shure: But it's really tasty.
Shure:  我一直特别爱吃
Shure: I've always loved it.
Shure:  李先生牛肉面
Shure: Mr. Lee's beef noodles.
Jake: 那就
Jake: Then let's...
Shure: 哦和府捞
Shure: Oh, Hefulao.
Shure:  呃不是啊
Shure: Uh, no.
Shure:  对和府捞面还还挺好
Shure: Yeah, Hefulao noodles are also good.
Shure:  挺好吃的啊
Shure: Quite tasty.
Shure:  那确实
Shure: Indeed.
Jake: 那就李先生吧
Jake: Then let's go with Mr. Lee's.
Jake: 李先生哈
Jake: Mr. Lee's, right?
Jake: 行吧
Jake: Alright.
Shure: 可以可以
Shure: Okay, okay.
Jake: 牛肉面
Jake: Beef noodles.
Jake: 行可以
Jake: Alright, sounds good.
Shure:  现在也不怎么练呢
Shure: I don't really practice much nowadays.
Jake: 哎点吧点吧
Jake: Hey, just order.
Shure:  你点完了
Shure: You're done ordering?
Nicous:  招牌牛肉面不用解释
Nicous: No need to explain the signature beef noodles.
Shure:  那我也不用解释招牌牛肉面你呢
Shure: Then I don't need to explain the signature beef noodles either. What about you?
Nicous:  我想说我也点这个
Nicous: I wanted to say I'll order this too.
Shure:  那你也给我改成这个
Shure: Then change mine to that as well.
Katrina: 那我就来三份这个
Katrina: Then I'll have three servings of this.
Nicous:  哈哈哈
Nicous: Hahaha.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Shure:  一二三三份
Shure: One, two, three... three servings.
Nicous: 你来试试吗
Nicous: Do you want to try?
Shure:  不是你手机背面那首歌
Shure: Isn't it the song on the back of your phone?
Nicous: 什么字啊
Nicous: What does it say?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Huh?
Shure: 听过这首歌吗
Shure: Have you heard this song?
Shure: 你滚
Shure: Get lost.
Nicous:  这这个是不是没写就不用夹子了
Nicous: If it's not written, do we still need the clip?
Shure:  不用夹子
Shure: No clip needed.
Nicous: 我直拦来
Nicous: I'll just block it directly.
Nicous:  我已经悟了
Nicous: I think I've got it.
Shure:  你真悟了吗
Shure: Have you really got it?
Shure:  不行我先给你示范一遍
Shure: No, let me demonstrate first.
Shure:  怎么样
Shure: How's that?
Nicous: 管用
Nicous: Useful.
Nicous: 根本
Nicous: Not at all.
Shure:  要不我先先
Shure: How about I go first?
Shure:  我先来一遍
Shure: I'll go first.
Shure:  哈哈哈啊
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina:  唱错了唱错了
Katrina: You sang it wrong, sang it wrong.
Katrina:  刚唱成那个
Katrina: You sang it like that.
Katrina:  你这听过吗
Katrina: Have you heard this before?
Shure:  没有你给我先哼一遍
Shure: No, hum it for me first.
Shure:  这首歌是哪的
Shure: Where's this song from?
Shure:  要不先从副歌开始
Shure: How about we start from the chorus?
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Shure:  乌拉乌拉那段也要弹吗
Shure: Do we have to play the "Ula Ula" part too?
Shure:  我真没听
Shure: I really haven't heard it.
Nicous: 每次我唱歌大哥你可别
Nicous: Every time I sing, big brother, you...
Nicous: 要不你先闭个麦
Nicous: How about you mute your mic first?
Shure:  就是如果我来写这首歌的话
Shure:  我会这么唱
Shure:  你懂吗
Nicous: 所以你能不能闭个麦
Lucia: 可以
Shure:  行
Shure:  哎呦我的妈
Shure:  这这这够够你摁了
Shure:  这是个大横摁
Shure:  就是要要这样摁哦哎
Shure:  那个然后之后是cm
Shure:  是这样摁的
Katrina: 这首歌也很好哼啊
Nicous: 我给你说个好玩了
Nicous:  我当时在那个KTV
Tasha: 那我要这个
Nicous:  想跟我对象录爱河姐
Nicous:  但我录错了录着
Katrina: 笑死啦
Shure:  不我
Shure:  我记得我这个副歌好像听过的
Shure: I think I've heard this chorus before.
Shure:  副歌怎么唱来着
Shure: How does the chorus go again?
Shure:  啊嗯
Shure: Ah, hmm.
Shure:  他这个刮刘和弦太多了
Shure: He's using too many glissando chords.
Shure:  难为我 好
Shure: It's tough for me, alright.
Katrina: 从头
Katrina: From the top.
Shure:  从头来吧
Shure: Let's start from the top.
Shure:  既然都点了
Shure: Since we're all set.